[Music]
thanks for being here I'm very excited
Conan I'm excited to be here I can tell
does that seem safe sincere oh this is
pure sincerity thanks for telling us
those your tears what is he doing with
his face he's touching it a lot
pitch-perfect what's first mentioned
workaholics very funny show
congratulations thank you very much
thank you things are all happening for
you have that nae of the movie ok pitch
perfect you just had the big movie
premiere did you you brought your
parents to the premiere until I did that
was a horrible decision why uh my mom
was inappropriately proud the entire
time
what do you mean inappropriate well we
gets to the red carpet and she's like
it's really red much like I did when I
just got here a second ago and then when
we're watching the film were in the
movie theater and she just every time I
wouldn't even be like talking or like
I'm just in the background just side
head and the camera would pass past me
and should be like oh my dad's like yeah
it's all happening yeah Emily theme with
us well okay you you sing in this movie
was anyone in your families like
surprised that you sing or do they know
that you're a singer uh well I I told my
dad I was like my dad was surprised I
was like yeah I'm doing this movie and
I'm like a little nervous cuz I have to
sing in it and he goes geez you should
because you suck you're horrible and I'm
like thank you and then actually after
the movie his way of like complimenting
me was like you sucked a lot less than I
thought you were going that's a good dad
he's a sweetheart of a man I picture him
holding a pitchfork laufey's yeah he
always read from the far